the chief diversity officer of Harvard
University stop the presses pull over
your car turns that that woman was just
caught plagiarizing her academic work I
know I know it's shocking because
Harvard you know would never be caught
up in a plagiarism Scandal and more to
it Chief diversity officers are held to
the absolute highest academic standards
right when I think of people who get
their jobs through Merit and Merit alone
I think of Chief University officers a
position that did not exist 5 years ago
and should not exist because it's a
Shakedown racket yeah they got her the
woman's name is Sher Anne Charleston
she's Harvard's first Chief diversity
and inclusion officer of course because
the position wasn't real it's still not
real but it didn't even exist on the on
payroll until just a handful of years
ago not only did she plagiarize remember
Claudine gay the recent former president
of Harvard she played ized something
like half of her academic
work this woman has plagiarized part of
every single publication that she has
ever written 40 uh in total 40 instances
of plagiarism in total looks like the
chief diversity officer had a a more
prolific publication record than the
former president of Harvard but I guess
it's cuz she was just cutting and
pasting a little bit more this all
thanks to reporting from the Washington
Free B
Aaron
saaran it's a great journalistic work
being done out
there cherry on top this woman served on
the committee the search committee that
picked Claudine gay the place is so
rotten we got to just keep picking at
this this is so this is like shooting
fish in a
barrel Chris rufo Aeron sarum some other
conservative journalists started this up
and now we just just pick them all off
just get them all
fired it's the perfect
tactic because
plagiarism is perfectly adapted to these
types of
people these types of people the pro Dei
the chief diversity officer the race
hustling ideologues of the left who get
installed in these positions they
are by definition poorly educated and
dishonest they're poorly educated if if
they were capable of doing real academic
work they would be in a real academic
field they would have a real academic
job but they can't they're not capable
of that so they end up doing these fake
pseudo academic Fields because it's
easier to get good grades and here's
where the dishonesty part comes in
here's where the deception part comes in
it's just a big hustle it's a big racket
where you can just aize your own fake
victimhood and the more you do that the
more lucrative it is for you so these
people self- select as being the most
the least educated most dishonest people
in Academia and we know that it's it's
on their business card okay let's just
pluck them all up just look down the
publication list of all these people
throw it into chat GPT throw it into
some AI program and say find me the
plagiarism it's going to it's going to
come up for like all of them okay and
that's a great way to do it the Liberals
will say this is a cynical approach
they'll say you've got a an end in mind
and uh you're just backfilling it you're
justifying the end in mind which is to
fire all these people with with the
justification that they engaged in
plagiarism to which I say You're darn
toon you bet I am I'm not saying that
the ends justify the means I'm not
saying that good ends justify immoral
means there's nothing immoral about
exposing plagiarism about explo exposing
a serious the highest academic offense
you can possibly commit and it's a good
academic end these people should not be
in these positions claudian gay this
woman Sherry and Charleston probably
most of these academic administrators
90% of whom didn't even exist their jobs
weren't weren't at the universities 10
20 years ago just get rid of all of them
that's the left's power center we've got
a major weakness here they still feel
some degree of Shame over that weakness
at least publicly they express it get
them all love it many more where that
came from right now go to G defy.com use
code
mk30 good Footwear is about more than
fashion what you wear on your feet
matters to your health your comfort your
well-being choosing Footwear that
provides support for your daily routine
is important now easier than ever thanks
to G defy shoes I love these shoes when
they came in I said I hope these aren't
running shoes you know me I'm not going
to wear running shoes you think I'm not
the most athletic guy and then I I take
out the first pair they're not running
shoes they were beautiful Oxford shoes
with nice really comfy soles and broing
even which I really like in my shoes and
then I opened the next one and they were
running shoes but they're the nicest
looking most comfortable running shoes I
have ever seen you have got to get G
defy I am I I love them because shoes
are not just about fashion but they're a
little bit about fashion and these just
hit the mark on both I love this company
your feet deserve more than just another
pair of shoes right now use code mk30
for 30 bucks off orders of 50 bucks or
more G the letter G defi DF
y.com gdf y.com promo code mk30 for 30
bucks off your purchase of 150 bucks or
more experience the miracle that is g
defi where Comfort meets Innovation
Korean jeanpierre over at the White
House was just asked about an a Very
inconvenience conflict in the way that
Joe Biden has talked about the Border
you see because when talking about how
Donald Trump dealt with the Border
Karine uh green Jean Pierre and the
White House and Joe Biden said that it
was very very racist if you ever want to
shut down the border at all very very
racist but then when Joe Biden starts to
talk about potentially shutting down the
border that is different
somehow back in the winter of 2018 and
the spring of 2019 president Trump vowed
to shut down the border with Mexico uh
using almost The Identical language that
the president used on Friday uh many
many if not most if not practically all
Democrats called that xenophobic and
even racist why uh shouldn't
people make the same conclusion about
this president's threat to shut down the
entire border with Mexican so we believe
the new enforcement tools uh that
currently don't exist that will be uh we
believe that will be part of this
bipartisan agreement uh will be fair We
Believe it'll yes it'll be tough but it
will be fair there are different
definition right of what that looks like
of what actually uh shutting down the
Border looks like right so we're going
to let them work through it we don't
know what that looks like exactly right
what we are asking for what the
president wants to see is that we deal
with the challenges at the
border there are not different
definitions of shutting down the Border
shut shutting has a clear meaning down
the Border those are all pretty clear
Concepts but she knows there's no it's
here I I'll give you the the answer how
is it that when Trump does something
it's racist but when Biden does the
exact same thing it's not racist
because Trump is Trump and Biden is
Biden that's how that's their answer I'm
not being glib um that's it that's their
real answer you know how black people
can't be
racist that's what they say I they can
obviously but they say black people
can't be racist because racism is when
white people do bad
thing or don't or do a thing that we
just disapprove of in any way or really
do anything at all that's racism it's in
the
definition they say racism is when white
person does such and such to black
person well the same thing is true here
for Democrats and
Republicans in the definition Democrats
can't be racist and Republicans are
racist so what's the solution to this
some Republicans want to try to flip it
on the Democrats and say no you're the
real racists you know you actually when
you really think about it you're the
real racists I I don't think that really
works I don't think the term means much
of anything at all I'm not sure that it
ever did mean much of anything at
all what is if now racism means you
think that white people are entitled to
any rights or respect in society which
is I think what the the Democrats mean
by it then just forget about it or if it
means that you I don't know you
recognize that there are different races
that's I think that's what they also
mean at least at least when white people
do it so I don't whatever it is just we
should forget about that okay we we
oppose Injustice we oppose cruelty we uh
think that things ought to be fair we so
we support all those
but you'll never win with racist you'll
never you'll never win using the
Democrats words you'll never win using
their framing you got to you got to give
people a new framing to see the world in
a new and more accurate way that's how
you win people over you make that normal
that was a great clip huh now hold up
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
nlls YouTube channel see you next time